The first thing you need to know about Lori is that normally she's not the kind of girl who does this sort of thing at all. She doesn't write to strangers. She doesn't do fan mail. But she was looking at-- you know the page in certain magazines where they have the little pictures of the people who write for the magazine? She was looking at that, and she saw the photo of this writer who she liked.
关于Lori，你需要知道的第一件事是，通常情况下，她根本不是那种会做这种事的人。她不会给陌生人写信，也不会写粉丝信。但她当时正在看——你知道，在某些杂志里，有专门介绍撰稿人的小版面，上面还有他们的照片？她当时就在看那个，然后看到了她喜欢的一位作家的照片。
The picture was blurry, but he had this intense look in his eye. And you could tell he was smart and cute. Both at the same time.
照片有些模糊，但他眼神里透着一种强烈的感觉。你能看出他既聪明又可爱。两者兼具。
But I saw this picture and I was like, that guy's my soul mate. I know that's completely insane, but I knew that I could not not contact him because I would aways regret it if I didn't. So I wrote this letter to the magazine, to him, care of the magazine. And I made up a story. I said, I know this is going to sound really weird, but I saw your picture on the contributors page, and you look exactly like this guy that I met in the airport years ago.
但我看到那张照片时心想，那个男人是我的灵魂伴侣。我知道这完全是疯了，但我知道我不能不联系他，因为如果不联系，我一定会后悔。于是我给杂志社写了这封信，寄给他，由杂志社转交。我编了一个故事。我说，我知道这听起来很奇怪，但我看到你在撰稿人页面上的照片，你长得跟我几年前在机场遇到的人一模一样。
This is a complete lie. So I said, I was changing planes and you were going into one gate and I was going into another, and we struck up this conversation. And you were talking about how you wanted to become a writer. And I said, I'm not sure if it's you. I know this sounds really strange, but if you remember this, let me know. And if it's not you, let me know also, just so that I know that it wasn't you.
这完全是个谎言。所以我说，我当时正在转机，你往一个登机口走，我往另一个走，我们聊了起来。你当时说你想成为一名作家。我说，我不确定是不是你。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但如果你记得这件事，请告诉我。如果不是你，也请告诉我，好让我知道那不是你。
Ah, very clever, though, the ending, that he basically has to call you even if he's not the guy, just to put your mind at ease.
啊，那个结尾很聪明，因为不管他是不是那个人，他基本上都必须给你回电话，好让你安心。
It was my way of getting to meet him.
这是我接近他的方式。
She figured that, in the extremely unlikely event that they actually sort of got along and it led to something bigger, well, then she would admit the truth, and no harm done. Remember, she had never done this kind of scam before. She had no idea how complicated it could get.
她当时想，如果极不可能发生的事情真的发生了，他们合得来，并且发展出了什么，那她到时候再承认真相，反正也没造成什么伤害。记住，她以前从未做过这种骗局。她根本不知道这事会变得多复杂。
So I don't hear from him, which I was relieved by, actually. After I sent the letter, I really regretted actually sending the letter. And I was glad that I never heard from him. And I was really glad the whole thing went away, because I was really sort of just embarrassed that I had done this.
所以我没收到他的回信，其实我当时还松了一口气。信寄出后，我真的很后悔寄了那封信。我很高兴我没收到他的回信。我很高兴这件事就这么过去了，因为我对自己做过的事感到非常尴尬。
So then one day, like three months later, I get a call. And I was actually waiting for the cable guy. I'd been waiting for, like, three days for the cable guy. So I'm on the phone with the cable company, and they're saying, the guy in the field is going to call you any second on your call waiting, so we're going to hang on with you while we contact him and he's going to call you.
后来有一天，大概三个月后，我接到了一个电话。当时我正在等有线电视安装工。我已经等了大概三天了。所以我正在和有线电视公司通话，他们说，外勤人员马上就会打你的呼叫等待电话，所以我们要在线上等你，等我们联系上他，他就会打给你。
So then my call waiting beeps in. And I say, hello. And the person says, is this Lori? And I say, yes. And the person says, I'm the guy. And I think he's the cable guy. So I say, where have you been? And he says, I know, I'm really sorry. I meant to contact you earlier. And this whole thing goes back and forth until I realize that he's not the cable guy. So I said, you're not the cable guy? And he says, no, I'm the guy from the airport.
接着我的呼叫等待响了。我说，你好。对方说，是Lori吗？我说，是的。对方说，我是那个人。我以为他是那个有线电视安装工。所以我说，你去哪儿了？他说，我知道，真的很抱歉。我本想早点联系你的。我们就这样来回说了半天，直到我意识到他不是有线电视安装工。所以我说，你不是那个安装工？他说，不是，我是机场里的那个人。
And I'm floored, because I can't believe that he's calling, that I'm actually on the phone with him, that I'm talking to this guy that I was momentarily obsessed with. And it's him. And he starts to tell me that he's really glad that he heard from me, because, yes, he's the guy from the airport. And what a coincidence, he's coming to LA to do a story the next day. And can we see each other again?
我彻底惊呆了，因为我不敢相信他竟然打电话来了，我竟然真的在和他通话，我正在和那个让我短暂迷恋过的人说话。真的是他。他开始对我说，他很高兴收到我的来信，因为是的，他就是机场里的那个人。而且真巧，他第二天要来洛杉矶做一个报道。我们能再见一面吗？
And I'm thinking to myself, again? This didn't happen. And I'm really worried that he thinks that I'm somebody else, like, maybe he met some other girl in the airport a long time ago and he thinks that I'm that girl. And when he meets me, he's going to be really disappointed that I'm not whoever he was thinking of. But I also don't want to correct him, because then I think if I tell him, you know what? Actually, I made the whole thing up, and I just wanted to get to meet you, he'll think I'm insane and he won't want to meet me. So I decide that I will meet him, but I will tell him the truth immediately upon meeting him.
我心想，再见？根本没那回事。我很担心他以为我是别人，比如，也许他很久以前在机场遇到了别的女孩，他以为我是那个女孩。当他见到我时，发现我不是他想的那个人，他会很失望。但我也不想纠正他，因为我想，如果我告诉他：你知道吗？其实我编造了整个故事，我只是想见你一面，他会觉得我疯了，就不会想见我了。所以我决定去见他，但一见到他，我就立刻告诉他真相。
Wait, you know there's a third option, and that is that he knows he didn't meet you, but he just wants to meet a girl.
等等，你知道还有第三种可能，那就是他知道他没见过你，但他只是想见个女孩。
I thought about that. And there was actually a fourth option, which was he knows that I'm screwing with him, and he's just getting back at me by kind of playing the game.
我想过那个可能。其实还有第四种可能，那就是他知道我在耍他，他只是在配合我玩这个游戏，以此作为报复。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. I mean, there were so many options that were just out of my experience or out of the experience of anything that I had heard about, that I couldn't imagine what was going on. And so, out of fear that I wouldn't be able to meet him, I decided to say nothing.
是的。我是说，有太多种可能是我从未经历过或听闻过的，我根本无法想象到底发生了什么。所以，出于怕见不到他的恐惧，我决定什么都不说。
I have to say, you were meeting him, like, for him to be the person on the phone when you're expecting the cable guy, did that make it seem more romantic? Like, you guys were meeting, so cute. Or did it make it feel like you didn't even want to deal?
我不得不说，当你以为是安装工，结果是他时，这是否让你觉得更浪漫了？比如，你们相遇的方式，很可爱。还是说，这让你觉得根本不想处理？
Oh, no. The minute I found out that it was him, I completely regressed back into my state of obsession. And in terms of meeting cute, actually he was coming to LA and I was going to New York, and we were going to miss each other completely. It was like a romantic comedy, but it turned out that my flight back to LA was an hour before his outgoing flight back to New York. So it turned out we were going to be in the same terminal at the same time at LAX. So he said, wouldn't it be great to meet in the airport again?
哦，不。我一旦发现是他，我就完全回到了那种迷恋的状态。至于“可爱邂逅”，其实他要来洛杉矶，而我要去纽约，我们完全要错过了。就像一部浪漫喜剧，但后来发现，我飞回洛杉矶的航班比他飞回纽约的航班早一个小时。所以结果就是，我们会在LAX机场的同一个航站楼。于是他说，在机场再见一面不是很好吗？
Which, of course, was the single most confusing thing that he could possibly say, because, on the one hand, how fated, how romantic comedy can you get, both at the airport, right? And on the other hand, what the hell is he talking about? They've never met.
这当然是他能说的最让人困惑的话了，因为一方面，这多有缘分，多浪漫喜剧，两个人都出现在机场，对吧？而另一方面，他到底在说什么？他们根本没见过面。
Well, today on our radio show, we have three stories of mind games, situations where a simple deception goes way out of hand and leads to all kinds of things that it was never intended to lead to. You're listening to This American Life, by the way, from Chicago Public Radio, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Later in our program today, we have the story of self-appointed secret agents, going around New York City hoping to serve the forces of good and not evil, until things get more emotional than they planned. And we have Scott Carrier talking about an invisible girl in Salt Lake City.
好吧，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有三个关于心理游戏的故事，在这些情况下，一个简单的谎言变得一发不可收拾，导致了各种意想不到的结果。顺便说一下，你正在收听的是芝加哥公共广播电台制作的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是Ira Glass。在今天节目的后面，我们将讲述一群自封的特工，他们在纽约市到处走动，希望能为正义效力，结果事情的发展比他们预想的更加情绪化。我们还有Scott Carrier谈论盐湖城的一个隐形女孩的故事。
But before we get any of that, consider what happened to Lori. Her travel plans change. She can't meet the guy at the airport. And so instead, she shows up and she has a drink with him at his hotel. And the first surprise is he looks nothing-- nothing-- like his picture.
但在那之前，先看看Lori发生了什么。她的旅行计划变了。她没能在机场见到那个男人。于是，她改在酒店和他喝了一杯。第一个惊喜是，他长得一点，一点都不像照片里的样子。
And I didn't quite know what to do about that, because he looked so unlike his picture that at that point I wondered if he was actually the guy, or if he had sent-- like he was playing a mind game with me, and he had sent some other guy to kind of go on the date with me.
我不知道该怎么办，因为他长得太不像照片里的人了，以至于那一刻我怀疑他到底是不是那个人，或者他是不是派了别人来——就像他在玩心理游戏，派了别人来跟我约会。
Wow. I love how, because you're running a con, suddenly you believe everybody is running a con.
哇。我喜欢这一点，因为你在行骗，所以你突然觉得每个人都在行骗。
Well, your sense of reality gets turned upside down. It's like you think I'm an honest person and I did this, so who knows what other people are doing.
嗯，你的现实感被颠覆了。就像你认为自己是个诚实的人，结果却做了这种事，所以谁知道别人在做什么呢。
So she sits there. And the longer she sits there, the more that she can see that, yes, when he turns his head this particular way, he probably is the guy in the photo. Not that that helps anything. She is not liking the real him, not attracted.
她坐在那儿。她坐的时间越长，就越能看出，是的，当他把头转向那个特定角度时，他可能就是照片里的那个人。但这并不能解决任何问题。她不喜欢真实的他，对他没感觉。
And because I'm not interested, I'm kind of deciding, do I need to even tell him that I made this up, or can I just leave?
因为我不感兴趣，我开始纠结：我需要告诉他我编造了这一切吗？还是我可以就这样离开？
Oh, right.
哦，对。
He doesn't need to know that I made up the story. But then, on the other hand, it was sort of strange because he kept talking about our encounter in the airport. And it was kind of frustrating to me, because I felt like, why is he doing this? I couldn't understand why he would do this. It wasn't just that he had seen my letter and kind of went with it. It was like, he then took the letter to a whole new level of deception.
他没必要知道我编了那个故事。但另一方面，这又很奇怪，因为他一直在谈论我们在机场的那次邂逅。这让我感到沮丧，因为我觉得，他为什么要这么做？我无法理解他为什么要这么做。这不仅仅是他看到我的信后顺水推舟那么简单。就好像，他把这封信带入了一个全新的欺骗层面。
First he said, when I met him at the bar, the first thing he said to me was, oh, I recognized you immediately. You look exactly the same as you did in the airport. Then, when we were talking, he'd just pepper the conversation with all these little lies, like he said that when we were in the airport he remembered that I was confused about what I wanted to do with my life. There were a bunch of little things. Oh, he said he remembered that I had grown up in Los Angeles, and he remembered where I had gone to college. And these were all things that he could have found out other ways.
首先，当我在酒吧见到他时，他说的第一件事就是，噢，我立刻就认出你了。你看起来和在机场时一模一样。然后，当我们交谈时，他会用各种小谎言填满对话，比如他说在机场时他记得我很迷茫，不知道自己的人生想做什么。还有一堆小事。噢，他说他记得我在洛杉矶长大，还记得我上过哪所大学。这些都是他可以通过其他方式查到的事情。
Like, just googling your name on the internet.
比如，在网上搜一下你的名字。
Yeah. So he says to me-- you know, the bar closes-- and he says, do you want to come up and continue talking? And I wanted to leave really badly at that point, but because I'd been there for so many hours, I thought, I cannot leave and not get to the bottom of this story. And I feel so guilty at this point that I really feel like I have to come clean.
是的。所以他对我——你知道，酒吧要打烊了——他说，你要不要上去继续聊？那时我真的很想离开，但因为我在那儿待了那么久，我想，我不能离开而不把这件事搞清楚。我当时感到非常内疚，觉得我必须坦白。
So I go upstairs and I say to him, you know, I have to tell you, I really don't think that you're the guy from the airport. It's been really nice meeting you, but you're not the guy. And he says, no, no, no, I am. And he's very insistent about it. And it's sort of like, once he had his own position, he didn't want to change his position.
所以我上楼对他说了，你知道，我得告诉你，我真的不认为你是那个机场里的男人。见到你很高兴，但你不是那个人。他说，不，不，不，我就是。他非常坚持。就好像，一旦他确立了自己的立场，就不想再改变了。
Right, it's embarrassing to say, no, no, no, I was just lying there. It's embarrassing.
对，说“不，不，不，我刚才只是在撒谎”太丢人了。这很尴尬。
Well, it's really embarrassing, especially if you've been so adamant about your position, which he had been. So I say to him, you know, actually it really wasn't you, because I made the whole thing up. And he is stunned into silence. And I think, oh, god, he thinks I'm a freak. And I'm sitting there thinking, I just want to crawl into a hole right now. I should never have told him the truth.
嗯，真的很尴尬，特别是如果你一直如此坚持自己的立场，而他确实坚持了。所以我对他说了，你知道，其实真的不是你，因为我编造了整个故事。他沉默了。我想，天哪，他一定觉得我是个怪胎。我坐在那儿想，我现在只想钻进地洞里。我真不该告诉他真相。
And then he just looks at me very calmly and says, no you didn't. I remember this. And I look at him like, what is he doing? I can't imagine what he's doing. Why is he doing that? Is he trying to save face for me? And he wasn't sort of excited about it. He was cool as a cucumber. He was like, no, it happened, I remember. And it was like it made me seem crazy. Like all of a sudden, it's like-- you know how you appear crazier when you're trying to prove to somebody that you're not crazy?
然后他非常平静地看着我说，没有，你没撒谎。我记得这件事。我看着他，心想他在干什么？我无法想象他在做什么。他为什么要那样说？他是在为我找台阶下吗？他并没有表现出兴奋。他冷静得像个黄瓜。他说，不，这事发生了，我记得。这让我显得像个疯子。就好像，当你想向别人证明你没疯时，你反而看起来更疯了，你知道那种感觉吗？
Yes.
是的。
And basically, I said, look, I gotta go. And oddly, then he said at the door, he's like, can I kiss you? And I just gave him my cheek. And then he gave me his card. And I left.
基本上，我说，看，我得走了。奇怪的是，他在门口竟然说，我可以吻你吗？我只是把脸颊凑了过去。然后他给了我一张名片。我就走了。
But there were only two possibilities. Either he actually believes that he met you, or he knows he didn't. Right?
但这只有两种可能性。要么他真的相信他见过你，要么他知道他没见过。对吧？
Right, but let's say that he believed that he met me. Reverse the situation. If somebody said to me, you know, I think I met you in the airport, and I believe them. And then they said, I made it all up. I would believe them. I would say, oh, huh. You know, I thought that actually you were telling the truth, but if you say you made it up, you must have made it up. What would be my motive for telling him I made the whole thing up?
对，但假设他相信他见过我。把情况反过来。如果有人对我说，你知道，我想我在机场见过你，而且我相信他们了。然后他们说，我全是编的。我会相信他们的。我会说，噢，哈。你知道，我原以为你说的是实话，但如果你说你是编的，那肯定就是编的。我有什么动机去告诉他我编造了整件事呢？
Yeah. I find that very convincing, actually. I wasn't actually sure what I thought up until you said that, but, actually, now I actually believe that he completely knew that he was lying. I actually believe there's no chance that he actually thought he met you.
是的。我觉得这很有说服力。在你这么说之前，我其实不确定我的想法，但现在，我确实认为他完全知道自己在撒谎。我真的认为他根本不可能以为他见过你。
There's no reason for him not to believe me, except for the fact that I've already established myself as a liar because I'm telling him I lied and sent you this note that was a complete lie.
他没理由不相信我，除非一个事实：我已经把自己塑造为一个骗子了，因为我正在告诉他我撒了谎，还给他发了一封彻头彻尾谎言的信。
I love how this started off as this innocent little romantic lie. And then, before it's done, you yourself are caught up in this whole world of where you can't even figure out how to convince him. And you can't figure out why he's saying what he's saying. Like, your mind so messed with by the end of this story.
我喜欢这件事的开始，它只是一个天真的小浪漫谎言。然后，在结束之前，你自己也陷入了这个世界，甚至无法弄清如何去说服他。你也搞不懂他为什么要那么说。在这个故事的结尾，你的大脑真的是一团乱。
Yeah. I don't know what to make of it. I mean, years later I don't know what to make of it. It's this thing that I sort of-- whatever went on in that room that night, it stayed with me for so many years because it was so confusing to me.
是的。我不知道该如何理解它。我是说，多年后我依然不知道该如何理解。这件事某种程度上——无论那天晚上在那房间里发生了什么，它困扰了我很多年，因为它让我太困惑了。
Lori Gottlieb. Her new book, Marry Him: The Case for Settling for Mr. Good Enough is coming out in February.
Lori Gottlieb。她的新书《嫁给他：选择“还不错”先生的理由》将于二月出版。
[MUSIC - "MR. MAGAZINE" BY THE KNACK]
[音乐 - The Knack乐队的《Mr. Magazine》]
Act Two, The Spy Who Loved Everyone. We have this story of good intentions and where they lead from Jorge Just.
第二幕，“爱过每个人的间谍”。我们有来自Jorge Just的这个关于善意及其结果的故事。
It's a Saturday in January, dead of winter, a crowded subway car, New York City.
一月的一个周六，隆冬，纽约地铁里挤满了人。
Stand clear of the closing doors, please.
请远离车门。
At the Canal Street station, a guy walks onto the car. He's wearing a hat, gloves, scarf, and coat, but no pants. At the next stop, Spring Street, someone else gets on with no pants. This continues for half a dozen stops. The car's filling up with pantless people who don't seem to know or even notice each other. Reactions vary.
在运河街站，一个人走进车厢。他戴着帽子、手套、围巾和外套，但没穿裤子。在下一站，春天街，又有一个没穿裤子的人上车了。这种情况持续了半打车站。车厢里挤满了似乎互不认识、甚至没有注意到彼此的没穿裤子的人。反应各不相同。
Some riders avert their eyes. Some laugh out loud. Some stare, turn away, stare again. Finally, at 33rd Street, somebody new comes through the car. It's a vendor. She's selling pants.
有的乘客避开视线。有的放声大笑。有的盯着看，转过头，又盯着看。最后，在第33街，有一个新人穿过车厢。是个小贩。她在卖裤子。
Big guys, tall guys. Short pants, medium pants. Anyone need pants? $1.
大个子，高个子。短裤，中裤。有人需要裤子吗？一美元。
It won't shock you to know that this whole scene was staged. The pantless people are part of a group called Improv Everywhere, led by a 26-year-old New Yorker named Charlie Todd. He pulls stunts like this all over New York. He calls them missions. The people that carry them out are called agents. Here's how Charlie explains it.
整个场景是精心设计的，这一点应该不会让你感到震惊。这些没穿裤子的人是“到处即兴”组织的一部分，由26岁的纽约人Charlie Todd领导。他在纽约各地搞这类噱头。他称之为“任务”。执行任务的人被称为特工。这是Charlie的解释。
It's always hard for me to describe it, because I always want to use the word "prank." But prank always has that negative connotation of, in order for there to be a prank, there has to be a victim. Somebody who has been fooled and has been embarrassed or humiliated or had the best of. And what we try to do is really the opposite. We try to make people happy.
我总是很难描述它，因为我总是想用“恶作剧”这个词。但恶作剧总是带有一种负面含义，即为了有恶作剧，就必须有一个受害者。有人被愚弄，感到尴尬或羞辱，或者被耍了。而我们试图做的事情恰恰相反。我们试图让人们开心。
For Charlie, happy means fun, and fun means making strange things happen in boring locations. Take mission 27, The Moebius.
对于Charlie来说，“开心”意味着有趣，而“有趣”意味着在无聊的地方让奇怪的事情发生。以第27号任务——莫比乌斯环为例。
The Moebius mission was a time loop in a Starbucks.
莫比乌斯任务是星巴克里的一个时间循环。
It worked like this-- Charlie and six friends choreographed a five-minute sequence of events to repeat over and over again. They planned it at a Starbucks, and they performed it at another, the one across the street. Each agent had their own action. Charlie and his girlfriend started off. They walk in and get in line. Charlie notices a pack of cigarettes in her purse and confronts her about her smoking.
它是这样运作的——Charlie和六个朋友精心策划了一系列重复进行的五分钟事件。他们在一家星巴克策划，在另一家，也就是街对面那家执行。每个特工都有自己的动作。Charlie和他的女朋友先开始。他们走进去排队。Charlie注意到她钱包里的香烟，并就她抽烟这件事质问她。
She says, don't tell me what to do, and storms out of the Starbucks. And I run out after her, yelling her name. Katie, come back. And then, four minutes later, we walk back into Starbucks, get in line again. And so that's our loop.
她说，别管我，然后冲出了星巴克。我追着她跑出去，喊着她的名字。Katie，回来。然后，四分钟后，我们又走回星巴克，重新排队。这就是我们的循环。
Agent number three spills his water, stands up, gets napkins, comes back to clean up the mess, and repeats. That's his loop. Agent number four answers a phone call, walks through the window for better reception, then goes back to his chair. Agent number five gets up to go to the bathroom, decides the line is too long, returns to his seat. Agent number six simply sneezes at a precise moment.
三号特工洒了水，站起来，拿餐巾纸，回来清理烂摊子，然后重复。那是他的循环。四号特工接了一个电话，穿过窗户以获得更好的信号，然后回到座位。五号特工站起来去洗手间，发现队伍太长，又回到了座位。六号特工只是在一个精确的时间点打了个喷嚏。
And the capper was my friend, Ken, would walk through the Starbucks with a boom box playing "Shiny Happy People" by R.E.M. And he would walk in one door, go through the entire restaurant, walk out the other door. We repeated that sequence 12 times in a row, for an hour total.
最后的一击是我的朋友Ken，他会带着一台音箱走过星巴克，播放R.E.M.的《Shiny Happy People》。他会从一个门进去，穿过整个餐厅，从另一个门走出去。我们将该序列连续重复了12次，总共一个小时。
Charlie says that for the first few repetitions, nobody noticed a thing. It was the argument between Charlie and his girlfriend that finally caught people's attention.
Charlie说，前几次重复时，没人注意到任何异常。正是Charlie和女朋友之间的争吵最终吸引了人们的注意力。
By, like, the third or fourth time that I had run out the Starbucks chasing after my girlfriend, people were starting to say, like, well, if I was him, I'd just break up with her. But it wasn't that they thought that they were in a time loop. It was that they thought that we really just kept getting into a fight.
大概到第三或第四次我追着女朋友跑出星巴克时，人们开始说，好吧，如果我是他，我早就跟她分手了。但他们并不是认为自己身处时间循环中。他们只是认为我们一直在吵架。
And then by, like, the fifth and sixth time that we did it, people kind of started to get freaked out. There was one woman in particular who we had on the hidden camera, who called her friend and said, you have to come down here. I'm at the Starbucks in Astor Place, and I don't know what's going on.
然后到第五或第六次时，人们开始有点被吓到了。特别是有个女人，我们用隐藏摄像头拍到了，她给朋友打电话说，你一定要来这里。我在阿斯特广场的星巴克，我不知道发生了什么。
I don't know if you've ever been in a Starbucks, but if you do go, you'll notice lots of people doing the same sort of thing over and over again. Sip the coffee, read the paper, update the blog. Stare hard enough and everyone looks like they're in a time loop. It took people almost an hour to find the line between staged scene and reality.
我不知道你是否去过星巴克，但如果你去过，你会发现很多人在反复做着同样的事情。喝咖啡，看报纸，更新博客。盯着看久了，每个人看起来都像是在时间循环里。人们花了一个小时才找到舞台场景和现实之间的界限。
By the end of it, by, like, the ninth and tenth time we're doing it, the whole Starbucks is talking to each other, participating in this thing. It's almost as if everybody in that Starbucks felt like they could predict the future. And they started kind of like conducting it, like they would point at Chris and say, oh, and he's going to sneeze right now. And here comes the boom box guy again. And oop, that means the couple's coming back, and there they are! And then, after the 12th time, we just left.
到最后，大约第九或第十次的时候，整个星巴克的人都在互相交谈，参与到这件事中。就好像星巴克里的每个人都觉得他们可以预见未来。他们开始指挥这一切，比如他们会指着Chris说，噢，他马上要打喷嚏了。音箱男又来了。哎呀，那意味着那对情侣要回来了，他们在那儿！然后，第12次后，我们就离开了。
In a way, this might be the most surprising part of the Moebius mission. After going to that much trouble just to provide a roomful of strangers with an unforgettable memory, the members of Improv Everywhere get up and they leave, and not just because you can't close the curtain on a coffee shop time loop. Charlie posts pictures and descriptions of the missions on his website, but that's as close as he gets to a standing ovation. He's got loftier goals, anyway.
从某种意义上说，这可能是莫比乌斯任务中最令人惊讶的部分。在为了给一屋子陌生人提供难忘的回忆而费尽周折之后，这些“到处即兴”的成员们起身离开，不仅仅是因为你不能给咖啡馆的时间循环拉上窗帘。Charlie在他的网站上发布了任务的照片和描述，但这已是他所能得到的最近似起立鼓掌的待遇了。反正他有更崇高的目标。
I want to live in a world where anything can happen. I guess what I mean by that is-- I don't know. I guess we shouldn't have to rely on television or movies to show us fantastic things and fantastic stories. Let's attempt to bring some of that excitement to the real world, I guess.
我想生活在一个任何事情都可能发生的世界里。我想我指的是——我不知道。我想我们不应该依赖电视或电影来向我们展示奇妙的事情和故事。让我们尝试把其中的一些兴奋带到现实世界中。
Charlie's missions are cool, but it's his objective that's intriguing-- to create fun, inexplicable experiences for random strangers. It's like giving people a small, unexpected gift, and in the process, making the world seem a bit more enchanted. But as anyone who's read a children's book can attest, mess with the forces of enchantment, and things can go terribly, terribly wrong. That's what happened with a mission Charlie calls the Best Gig Ever.
Charlie的任务很酷，但他引人入胜的目标是——为随机的陌生人创造有趣、莫名其妙的经历。这就像给人们一份微小、出人意料的礼物，并在此过程中，让世界看起来更有魅力。但正如任何读过儿童书的人所能证明的，干扰魔法力量，事情可能会变得非常、非常糟糕。这就是Charlie所谓的“史上最棒演出”任务中发生的事情。
The Best Gig Ever, an idea. My friend, Mark Lee, came up to me one night. And he came up to me and said, let's find a rock band, a struggling rock band, and give them the greatest gig of their life. So I researched on the internet for the next couple of weeks, trying to find the perfect gig, the perfect band who I knew was setting themselves up for just a horrible audience.
史上最棒演出，一个点子。我的朋友Mark Lee一天晚上来找我。他跟我说，我们找一支摇滚乐队，一支挣扎中的摇滚乐队，给他们一场一生中最棒的演出。所以我在接下来的几周里在互联网上进行了研究，试图找到完美的演出，找到一支我知道正处于面对糟糕观众境地的乐队。
And I found this band, Ghosts of Pasha, from Vermont. Never heard of them before. Nobody in New York had probably heard of them, apart from their friends, because it was their first tour ever. And they had just recorded some songs this summer, and they were going to tour in October. And they were playing a gig in New York on Friday night at 8 o'clock for a $5 cover.
我找到了这支乐队，来自佛蒙特州的Ghosts of Pasha。以前从没听说过他们。除了他们的朋友外，纽约大概没人听说过，因为这是他们的第一次巡演。他们今年夏天刚录了一些歌，打算十月份巡演。他们周五晚上8点在纽约有一场演出，票价5美元。
Then they had a gig two nights later on Sunday night at the Mercury Lounge, for an $8 cover at 10:00 PM. So I knew, even if they had friends in New York, those friends would come to the Friday night show, and they would not come back, no matter how good the show was. They're not coming out at 10 o'clock on a Sunday night to support their friends again.
然后两天后的周日晚上10点，他们在Mercury Lounge还有一场演出，票价8美元。所以我知道，即使他们在纽约有朋友，那些朋友也会来周五晚上的演出，而他们不会再来第二次，无论演出有多好。他们不会在周日晚上10点出来支持他们的朋友。
Charlie recruited 35 agents to act as hardcore Ghosts of Pasha fans. They downloaded the six songs on the band's website, and they memorized the lyrics. Some agents made T-shirts and temporary tattoos using the Ghosts of Pasha logo. They timed their arrival, getting to the club as the next-to-last band was getting off the stage.
Charlie招募了35名特工，扮演Ghosts of Pasha的忠实粉丝。他们下载了乐队网站上的六首歌，背下了歌词。一些特工用Ghosts of Pasha的标志制作了T恤和临时纹身。他们计算好了到达时间，在倒数第二支乐队下台时进入俱乐部。
People entered separately or in pairs, didn't act like we knew each other. And by the time they were doing their sound check, all of us were in the room. Not only were they getting ready to perform, we were getting ready to perform, too. And everybody from the previous gig had left. They had three paying customers that night, not counting us.
人们分别或结对进入，表现得好像互不认识。当他们进行试音时，我们所有人都已经在场了。不仅他们在准备演出，我们也在准备演出。前一场演出的人都已经走了。那天晚上他们有三名付费顾客，不包括我们。
But instead, they had 38, the 35 of us and the three paying customers. And once they got on stage and said, hello, Mercury Lounge, or whatever they said, we definitely exploded.
相反，他们有38个观众，我们35个加上那三名付费顾客。一旦他们登上舞台说，你好，Mercury Lounge，或者他们说了什么，我们绝对炸开了锅。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
We're Ghosts of Pasha.
我们是Ghosts of Pasha。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
You're listening to footage from a video camera that one of Charlie's friends snuck into the Mercury. The club was dark and the camera was hidden in a bag. At first, you can't make anything out, but then the camera goes into night vision mode, and it's all there in black and pale green and white. 35 people isn't much of a crowd, but somehow they make it seem like the place is packed.
你正在收听的是Charlie的朋友偷偷带进Mercury俱乐部的摄像机镜头。俱乐部很暗，摄像机藏在包里。起初，你什么也看不清，但后来摄像机进入了夜视模式，所有的一切都以黑色、浅绿色和白色呈现出来。35个人不算多，但不知何故，他们让那个地方看起来挤满了人。
I sat and watched the video with Charlie, who pointed out his favorite moments, and showed me how the agents reacted to the music in their own particular ways. Some pushing to the front, others hanging back. He points out another guy near the front of the stage, who's dancing spastically, flinging his arms, shaking to the music.
我和Charlie一起看视频，他指出了他最喜欢的瞬间，向我展示了特工们是如何以各自特定的方式对音乐做出反应的。有的挤到前面，有的站在后面。他指出舞台前方另一个男人，他正痉挛般地跳舞，挥动双臂，随着音乐摇摆。
At a show, there is always that one guy who's dancing too much. And like, the guy we're looking at now, he's that guy. So it's appropriate. We're not all doing it, but he is.
在演出中，总有那么一个跳得太过火的人。就像我们现在看到的这个人，他就是那个人。所以很合适。我们没全这么做，但他这么做了。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
Charlie spends most of the show taking pictures. Each rock crowd has one of those kids, too. But at a certain moment, even he gets swept up in the excitement and starts acting more like he does when he's seeing his favorite band, The Cure.
Charlie大部分演出时间都在拍照。每群摇滚粉丝里都有那么一个孩子。但在某个时刻，即使他也沉浸在兴奋之中，开始表现得更像他看自己最喜欢的乐队The Cure时的样子。
I will say that, at this moment right here, I am definitely into the show.
我想说，就在这一刻，我绝对完全投入到了演出中。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
We were requesting songs. We only knew the names of, like, six songs, because they only had six songs on their EP, which they had on their website. And I was screaming for, they have a song called, "What About the Shut-ins." It's like [SINGING] What about the shut-ins of the Second World War.
我们在点歌。我们只知道六首歌的名字，因为他们在EP里只有六首歌，就在他们的网站上。我当时在尖叫，他们有一首歌叫《What About the Shut-ins》。就像[唱歌]What about the shut-ins of the Second World War.
And I was screaming for "Shut-ins." I was just yelling, shut-ins! Shut-ins! And they played it. I think, probably coincidentally, they were playing it next on the set. And I just went crazy. When they started, when I heard the first notes, I was like, yeah! I got my request.
我一直在尖叫要唱《Shut-ins》。我只是在喊，Shut-ins！Shut-ins！他们唱了。我想，大概很巧合的是，他们接下来的曲目就是那首。我简直疯了。当他们开始唱，当我听到第一个音符时，我想，耶！我点歌成功了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
Where's the difference in really, really being into a band and pretending to be really into a band?
真正热爱一支乐队和假装热爱一支乐队有什么区别？
Yeah, there's not much difference. For that night, it felt just like I was at a Cure show, singing along to "Just Like Heaven." You know, I was at Ghosts of Pasha, singing along to "What About the Shut-ins." It was, whatever. It was the same thing, basically.
是的，没什么区别。那天晚上，感觉就像我正在参加The Cure的演出，跟着唱《Just Like Heaven》。你知道，我在Ghosts of Pasha的演出里，跟着唱《What About the Shut-ins》。总之，就是这样。基本上是一回事。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
Pasha, Pasha, Pasha, Pasha.
Pasha，Pasha，Pasha，Pasha。
Thanks a lot. Audience, audience, audience, audience.
多谢。观众，观众，观众，观众。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
The band gets offstage, and Charlie and company leave the bar to go celebrate another mission accomplished. A couple of days later, he puts up pictures and reports of the evening on his website. Charlie figured the band would find his page in a month or two. It's basically inevitable once he's posted everything online. What he wasn't sure of is how they would react.
乐队下台了，Charlie和同伴离开酒吧去庆祝另一个任务完成。几天后，他在他的网站上发布了当晚的照片和报道。Charlie估计乐队会在一两个月内找到他的主页。一旦他把所有东西都发到网上，这基本上是不可避免的。他不确定的是他们会有什么反应。
When I would tell people this idea, like, as I was preparing for this event, one of the main responses I got was people saying, like, that is so cruel. What's going to happen when this band does their next gig in your city and nobody shows up? That is the cruelest thing I've ever heard. And I really don't buy into that logic. I mean, it's kind of an interesting thing to think about. Like, is it cruel to give somebody the best day of their life just because they'll never have another day like that again? And I don't think so.
当我告诉人们这个想法，就在我准备这个活动时，我得到的主要反应之一是人们说，这太残忍了。当这支乐队在你的城市进行下一场演出却没人来时会发生什么？这是我听过最残忍的事情。我真的不认同那种逻辑。我是说，这其实是个很有趣的话题。给某人一生中最美好的一天，仅仅因为他们再也不会有那样的日子了，这算残忍吗？我不觉得。
I mean, it's kind of like you have a wonderful dream and you wake up. Do you wish you just have bad dreams every night? Or is it-- you know. And I think it's great to have wonderful dreams. And yeah, it kind of sucks for a second, but you'll always have that moment.
我是说，这有点像你做了一个美梦，然后醒来了。你希望自己每晚都做噩梦吗？还是——你知道。我认为拥有美梦很棒。是的，那一瞬间确实有点糟糕，但你永远拥有那一刻。
Pasha, Pasha, Pasha, Pasha, Pasha, Pasha, Pasha.
Pasha，Pasha，Pasha，Pasha，Pasha，Pasha，Pasha。
We got punked. That show at the Mercury Lounge was a fake. And it just seemed like a blow. Like, it was like a blow to my heart.
我们被整了。Mercury Lounge的那场演出是假的。这就像是一个打击。就像是对我心脏的一记重击。
This is Chris Partyka, the guitarist of Ghosts of Pasha. It turns out that finding Charlie's website was a bit worse than waking from a dream. And it happened faster than Charlie expected. Lead singer Milo Finch found out only three days after the show. His discovery was a disturbing capper to an already long and bizarre few days.
这是Chris Partyka，Ghosts of Pasha的吉他手。事实证明，找到Charlie的网站比从梦中惊醒还要糟糕。而且发生的速度比Charlie预想的要快。主唱Milo Finch在演出后仅三天就发现了。他的发现对这原本漫长而离奇的几天来说，是一个令人不安的结尾。
To understand how weird this was for the band, you need to hear the story from their perspective. They hadn't even wanted to play the Mercury show in the first place. They were exhausted. They'd just driven from Vermont to Boston for a show Thursday, and to New York for a show on Friday. Ezra, the drummer, and Brad, the bassist, had then driven the six hours back to Vermont on Saturday, then turned around and returned Sunday. Milo stayed in New York, but he'd been up all night partying.
要了解这对乐队来说有多离奇，你需要从他们的角度听这个故事。他们根本不想参加Mercury的那场演出。他们精疲力竭。他们刚从佛蒙特开车到波士顿参加周四的演出，又赶到纽约参加周五的演出。鼓手Ezra和贝斯手Brad然后在周六开车六小时回到佛蒙特，周日又掉头赶回来。Milo留在纽约，但他通宵聚会，没睡过觉。
I remember being on the street before the Mercury Lounge show, completely exhausted, just sitting on the street waiting to play. We didn't want to do it. I remember just sitting there, and it was pretty dead. We thought it was just going to be dead. And we were like, cool. It'd be dead. We could just go up there and play and just get out of there.
我记得在Mercury Lounge演出前我在街上，完全筋疲力尽，只是坐在街上等着演出。我们不想做。我记得只是坐在那儿，当时挺冷清的。我们以为演出肯定会很冷清。我们当时想，酷。那就冷清好了。我们可以直接上去唱完然后离开。
Get it over with.
快点结束它。
It turns out that the band Charlie picked wasn't just obscure, it was practically brand-new. They'd only been together a couple of months. This was their fourth show ever, the third on their tour.
事实证明，Charlie选的这支乐队不仅不出名，简直是全新的。他们在一起才几个月。这是他们有史以来的第四场演出，巡演的第三场。
It was really weird, because we knew this was our third show. I remember turning to the drummer, to Ezra, and being like, what's going on? Like, in the middle of a song, like, a drum break.
这真的很奇怪，因为我们知道这是我们的第三场演出。我记得转头对鼓手Ezra说，发生了什么？在歌曲中间，像鼓间奏的时候。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
What started weird soon got weirder. Keep in mind, they hadn't put out an album. Nobody anywhere had ever heard of them. But somehow, a crowd of New Yorkers knew their lyrics.
奇怪的事很快变得更奇怪了。记住，他们还没出过专辑。没有任何地方的人听说过他们。但不知何故，一群纽约人却知道他们的歌词。
The first song we noticed it was in "New York, New York," one of our songs. And right off the bat, as the chorus, and they came right in with it. I think they came in with it on better timing than I did. They came in right in. And they nailed it.
第一首我们注意到的是《New York, New York》，我们的一首歌。刚开始，唱到副歌，他们就立刻跟着唱起来。我觉得他们跟唱的时机比我还准。他们直接切入，而且唱得完美无缺。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
Honestly, it was really odd. I mean, there was moments where guys were ripping off their shirts and swinging them over their heads in, like, helicopter fashion. There were girls that were pointing at the stage and interacting with me as we were pointing back. It was just like bedlam.
老实说，真的很奇怪。我是说，有那么一瞬间，男人们扯掉衬衫，像直升机一样在头顶挥舞。有女孩指着舞台，在我们指回去时与我互动。简直就是一片混乱。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
The exclamation point on the whole evening for me was how creepy it was when the guy jumped up on stage with no shirt. And I just remember him being up front the whole time, punching the air and spinning in circles, and he was all sweaty. And he jumped up on stage at the end of the last song and hugged me. He's all sweaty and clammy, and he's like, thank you. Like, he just kept saying thank you in my ear.
整个晚上最让我印象深刻的是那个没穿衬衫的男人跳上舞台时有多恶心。我只记得他一直都在前排，对着空气挥拳，随着音乐转圈，满身大汗。在最后一首歌结束时，他跳上舞台抱住我。他全身又湿又粘，他说，谢谢。他就一直在我耳边说谢谢。
And I was just like, all right, thank you. You know what I mean?
我当时就想，好吧，谢谢。你懂我的意思吗？
Agent V.
特工V。
Yeah, Agent V. He seemed like he wasn't really acting, just getting it out.
是的，特工V。他看起来不像是在演戏，只是在宣泄。
The band got into it, too. Milo's favorite moment came at the end of the set.
乐队也投入其中了。Milo最喜欢的瞬间出现在演出快结束时。
During the solo on "Power Bitch." I had kind of just laid on the stage. The crowd rushed the stage was grabbing my hands like this, because I was right on the lip of the stage. And I put the microphone out into the audience, and they were screaming, grabbing at my hand and touching the microphone. And I made sure I slapped every hand that came up, just so no one felt like they didn't get it. And however the act was going on, or whatever they were pulling, or whatever they were doing, I felt that, at that point in the show, we answered it back with something real. And everybody was, at that point, everybody in the room was on the same page.
在《Power Bitch》的独奏期间。我就那样躺在舞台上。人群冲向舞台，像这样抓着我的手，因为我就在舞台边缘。我把麦克风伸向观众，他们尖叫着，抓着我的手，触摸麦克风。我确保我拍了每一只伸出来的手，好让没人觉得他们没参与到。无论他们在演什么戏，或者他们在搞什么鬼，我当时觉得，在演出那一刻，我们用真实的东西回应了它。那一刻，房间里的每个人都在同一频道上。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
One more song, one more song, one more song, one more song.
再来一首，再来一首，再来一首，再来一首。
The show was exhausting. They'd played the tour's first ever encore, and left all the energy they had onstage. Like Milo said, when a crowd screams at you like you're the Beatles, you act like you're the Beatles. Only this crowd stopped screaming the moment the last minutes were played. Chris remembers unplugging his amp, looking up, and being shocked that the place was empty. Ghosts of Pasha were suddenly alone.
演出让人精疲力竭。他们完成了巡演的第一次返场，留下了舞台上所有的能量。就像Milo说的，当人群像对待披头士那样对你尖叫时，你就会表现得像披头士。只有这群人在最后一分钟结束时停止了尖叫。Chris记得他拔掉音箱电源，抬头一看，惊讶地发现地方空了。Ghosts of Pasha突然孤身一人。
I remember we were all standing out on the street, smoking our cigarette after the show, and totally confused. Kind of speechless for a little bit. I think Brad broke the silence. He's always good for breaking the silence. He was like, what the [BLEEP] just happened? What the hell was that, I think was the-- what the hell was that? As he was lighting his cigarette. It was just creepy.
我记得演出后我们都站在街上，抽着烟，完全困惑了。有一阵子说不出话来。我想是Brad打破了沉默。他总是很擅长打破沉默。他说，刚才到底发生了什么鬼？我想那大概是——刚才到底是怎么回事？他点烟的时候。简直毛骨悚然。
Creepy, but also pretty sweet.
毛骨悚然，但也很贴心。
We just had nothing in our heads, so we just decided to fill it with, well, OK, we're really excited and we're in a really good mood, so this is great. Finally, 35 people from New York City randomly came to our show and knew our words and stuff, and that's a good feeling.
我们当时脑子里一片空白，所以我们决定用“好吧，我们真的很兴奋，心情很好，所以这很棒”来填补。最终，来自纽约市的35个人随机来到我们的演出，知道我们的歌词什么的，那是一种很好的感觉。
You know what it was? I think some of the talking was, we were addicted to it. We were like, that felt really cool. Like, let's play like that all the time. Let's get shows like that all the time.
你知道那是为什么吗？我想有些谈话内容是，我们对它上瘾了。我们想，那感觉真酷。我们要一直那样表演。我们要一直搞那样的演出。
That warm feeling lasted exactly three days, until somebody emailed them a link to Charlie's site. The band met up at the local computer lab and read it together. The next 48 hours were the worst. Email poured in mocking Ghosts of Pasha. Their website's bulletin board was flooded with people making fun of them. It got so bad they had to shut it down.
那种温暖的感觉持续了整整三天，直到有人给他们发了Charlie网站的链接。乐队在当地的电脑室见了面，一起读了它。接下来的48小时是最糟糕的。嘲笑Ghosts of Pasha的邮件蜂拥而至。他们网站的留言板被取笑他们的人淹没了。情况变得太糟，他们不得不关掉它。
The band felt like the butt of a big joke. They struggled to take it all in stride, but, inevitably, one member would get mad and the others would have to talk him down. A couple of hours later, they'd be on the phone with each other again, making each other angry, calming each other down.
乐队觉得自己成了一个大笑话的众矢之的。他们努力坦然面对，但不可避免地，一个成员会生气，其他成员必须劝他。几个小时后，他们会再次通电话，互相惹火，又互相安慰。
The guitarist, Chris Partyka, was most affected. He got teased a lot as a kid, which is why he started playing music in the first place. It was something he could do by himself in his room, where nobody could make fun of him. News of the prank hit Chris pretty hard.
吉他手Chris Partyka受到的影响最大。他小时候经常被取笑，这就是他一开始玩音乐的原因。这是他可以一个人在房间里做的事情，没人能嘲笑他。恶作剧的新闻对Chris打击很大。
It's the worst thing I could possibly think of ever happening to me in my life, because I'd been avoiding confrontation my whole life so I wouldn't get made fun of. And the moment I decide that I want to try and be real and do what I really want to do, all of a sudden it's reacted in the same way as it was when I was in kindergarten. And it's just like, what is the difference? I'm 30 years old now and I'm still getting made fun of by people.
这是我一生中能想到的最糟糕的事情，因为我一辈子都在回避冲突，免得被取笑。而当我决定尝试真实地做我想做的事情的那一刻，它突然又得到了和我幼儿园时一样的反应。这就像是，有什么区别呢？我现在30岁了，还在被人取笑。
Knowing all this, it's surprising how Chris feels about it now, six months after it happened.
知道了这一切，Chris现在对它的感觉很令人惊讶，距离这件事发生已经六个月了。
It was a gift. It was the gift of, like, yeah, everything's OK. At this point, I don't really feel like anything can hurt me, because I've dealt with what I've never thought that I could deal with before. It was like psychotherapy for my childhood. You know what I mean? Like, everybody in the world, look at Chris, and everyone's like, duh, look at him, duh. And then, what am I supposed to do with that but be like, hey, how you doing? I'm Chris. I play the guitar, and I like it.
这是一份礼物。这是一份“耶，一切都很好”的礼物。此时此刻，我觉得没什么能伤害我，因为我处理了以前从未想过能处理的事情。这就像是我童年的心理治疗。你懂我的意思吗？就像世界上每个人都看着Chris，大家都像，哈，看他，哈。然后，我除了说“嘿，你好吗？我是Chris。我弹吉他，而且我喜欢它”，还能做什么呢？
After mulling it over for a few days, the band decided what to do. They wrote into Charlie's website with their enthusiastic reports of the evening. Brad, the bassist, was terse. Chris, the guitarist, was thoughtful. And Milo, the lead singer, was the lead singer. Here's Charlie.
琢磨了几天后，乐队决定怎么办。他们写信给Charlie的网站，汇报了当晚的热情情况。贝斯手Brad言简意赅。吉他手Chris心思缜密。主唱Milo依然是主唱。这是Charlie。
The lead singer was really enthusiastic and upbeat about the whole thing. I mean, you could tell that he definitely had like, if not an ego, definitely had a lot of pride in the band, and made that clear, too. He had one line in his report that said, like, no matter what happened, we rocked the house that night, and you knew it. There were elements of like, we realize that it was a prank, but just so you know, we did rock it. Which, I agree with him. They did, they rocked it.
主唱对整件事表现得非常热情和乐观。我是说，你能看出他绝对有，如果不是自负，也绝对对乐队有很大的自豪感，而且也表达得很清楚。他在报道里有一句话说，无论发生了什么，我们那天晚上确实摇滚了全场，而且你知道这一点。这些元素就像是，我们意识到这是个恶作剧，但你要知道，我们确实很摇滚。这一点我同意他。他们确实做到了，他们摇滚了。
They rocked the show and snatched the opportunity. Bands need publicity, and Ghosts of Pasha knew a happy story sells better than a sad one. And they were right. The band was interviewed in Spin Magazine. An A&R guy gave them a call. In other words, Ghosts of Pasha played along. They took Charlie's story about what happened that night and made it their own.
他们摇滚了演出并抓住了机会。乐队需要宣传，Ghosts of Pasha知道一个快乐的故事比悲伤的故事更好卖。他们是对的。《Spin》杂志采访了这支乐队。一位A&R人员给他们打了电话。换句话说，Ghosts of Pasha将计就计。他们接受了Charlie关于当晚发生了什么的叙述，并使之成为他们自己的。
But not everybody's ready to make themselves at home in Charlie's world. Some people prefer their life just the way it is.
但不是每个人都准备好在Charlie的世界里安家。有些人更喜欢他们的生活原封不动。
All right, my name's Christopher Rawson. I am a fine arts student. I'm going to New York University. And they basically threw me a fake birthday party.
好的，我叫Christopher Rawson。我是艺术系学生。我在纽约大学。他们基本上给我办了一个假生日派对。
The idea was to throw a birthday party for a stranger, go up to someone in a bar, at random, and act like it was his birthday.
主意是给一个陌生人办生日派对，在酒吧里随机找个人，假装是他生日。
Charlie gathered about 30 Improv Everywhere agents, and headed to a bar called Dempsy's to pick the evening star. He decided on Chris, who was sitting with a friend and a full pitcher of beer. They looked like they were settling in for the night. Charlie called the other agents and described Chris, and then he walked over and started the party.
Charlie集结了大约30名“到处即兴”特工，前往一家叫Dempsy's的酒吧挑选当晚之星。他选定了Chris，他正和朋友坐着，面前有一大扎啤酒。他们看起来正准备在那儿待一晚。Charlie叫了其他特工并描述了Chris，然后走过去开始了派对。
And I said, hey, Ted, how's it going? Sorry we're a little early for your birthday party. But thank you for inviting us.
我说，嘿，Ted，最近怎么样？抱歉我们提前了一点来参加你的生日派对。但谢谢你邀请我们。
They came up to me, and they were like, you know, just really addressed me as this other person, as Ted, and were just like, hey, what's up buddy? Happy birthday.
他们向我走来，就是真的把我当成另一个人，Ted，只是说，嘿，怎么了哥们？生日快乐。
And he looks at me. And at first, he thinks it's just a case of misunderstanding. He's like, oh, I'm sorry, you've got the wrong guy. I'm not Ted. And I just laughed, and said, that's really funny, Ted. You did invite us to your birthday party, We got the evite.
他看着我。起初，他以为只是误会了。他说，噢，不好意思，你们认错人了。我不是Ted。我只是笑了笑，说，这真有趣，Ted。是你邀请我们参加你生日派对的，我们收到了电子请柬。
A few minutes later, more people started coming in and everybody was wishing me happy birthday and calling me by Ted. And everybody seemed to have this memory or this experience that they had with me in the past, which obviously was completely foreign to me.
几分钟后，更多人开始进来，每个人都在祝我生日快乐，叫我Ted。每个人似乎都有某种过去我和他们在一起的记忆或经历，这对我来说显然完全陌生。
I had sent out an email to everybody involved with some specifics about this guy, Ted Hine, and said that he was 25 years old, that he went to the UNC-Chapel Hill, that he worked at Oppenheimer Funds, that his favorite band was Dave Matthews. Like, we came up with all these specifics about him. And I told everybody, like, pick out what your relationship is to Ted, figure out what your story is and stick to it.
我给所有相关人员发了一封电子邮件，包含了一些关于这个男人Ted Hine的细节，说他25岁，毕业于北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校，在奥本海默基金工作，最喜欢的乐队是Dave Matthews。我们就他编造了所有这些细节。我告诉每个人，选好你和Ted的关系，确定你的故事，并坚持下去。
People were giving me hugs and being like, oh, I haven't seen you in so long. What have you been up to? And they had all kind of brought in little gift cards, and on all of them they said, remember spring break, things relating to school. A few of the people thought I worked for some sort of bank or something.
人们拥抱我，表现得好像，噢，我好久没见你了。你最近在忙什么？他们都带了小礼品卡，上面都写着，记得春假吗？学校里的事。其中几个人以为我在什么银行工作。
And he got really freaked out, which I didn't necessarily anticipate. But looking back on it, I guess I probably should have anticipated that that would freak somebody out.
他真的被吓坏了，这我没太预料到。但回想起来，我想我大概早该预料到那会吓到某人。
I was definitely freaked out and suspicious. I mean, it seemed very confrontational and very grotesque even, I would say. So yeah, it was kind of like a really bad dream.
我绝对被吓坏了，而且很怀疑。我是说，这看起来非常具有对抗性，甚至可以说是非常怪诞。所以是的，就像一场噩梦。
Chris, it turns out, wasn't the brash 25-year-old East Villager that Charlie thought he'd chosen. He was actually a college student, a very young one, who had recently transferred to NYU. If Charlie's the kind of guy who goes out in the world and makes things happen, then Chris is the kind who stays closer to home. He's thoughtful and sensitive and shy. Chris likes to have things in a certain, understandable order, and Charlie wasn't part of it.
事实证明，Chris并不是Charlie以为他选的那种冒失的25岁东村人。他其实是个大学生，非常年轻，刚转学到纽约大学。如果Charlie是那种走进世界并让事情发生的人，那么Chris就是那种离家更近的人。他心思细腻、敏感且害羞。Chris喜欢事情井井有条、可以理解，而Charlie并不在其中。
There was no sense that it was kind of a charade. I mean, it all felt very natural. It felt really close to reality, but yet it was so strange and different that it couldn't be. So there was definitely the worry, too, on my part, I guess, that I was going insane maybe, because it made no sense. So I kind of felt like I was losing my mind in that sense, like, the ability to rationalize what was happening, because I really couldn't.
没有任何感觉说这是一个骗局。我是说，一切都感觉非常自然。感觉非常接近现实，但又是如此奇怪和不同，不可能是真的。所以，我当然也担心自己是不是疯了，因为它说不通。所以我有一种我在某种意义上精神失常的感觉，就是说，理性化正在发生的事情的能力，因为我真的做不到。
He showed them his driver's license, but they laughed it off. And Chris couldn't shake the feeling that a guy named Ted, the real Ted, could show up at any moment to find Chris drinking Ted's free drinks, and even worse, blowing out Ted's candles and eating Ted's cake. But every time he tried to leave, a fake friend would stop him, beg him to stay, buy him a drink. And eventually, he just became Ted.
他向他们出示了驾照，但他们一笑置之。Chris无法摆脱那种感觉：一个叫Ted的家伙，真正的Ted，随时可能出现，发现Chris在喝Ted的免费饮料，更糟糕的是，吹灭Ted的蜡烛，吃Ted的蛋糕。但每次他想离开，一个假朋友就会拦住他，求他留下，给他买饮料。最终，他变成了Ted。
It was pretty much my only option. I think that was the moment of the shift, was kind of realizing that I was like, OK, well, if they all think I'm Ted, then what the hell.
这基本上是我唯一的选择。我想那一刻是转变的时刻，意识到我当时想，好的，好吧，既然他们都以为我是Ted，那就去他的吧。
He starts answering to Ted. He starts introducing himself as Ted to kind of the late comers. In the end, he was not only just agreeing that he was Ted, like, he was corroborating all of our stories.
他开始以Ted自称。他开始向晚到的人介绍自己是Ted。最后，他不仅同意他是Ted，而且他还印证了我们所有的故事。
People were like, oh, remember this? And I was like, oh, yeah, that was great. What a great time. And just kind of played along with it. I think I just kind of decided that maybe I could, by assuming that identity, have some control or some say in the situation.
人们说，噢，记得这个吗？我说，噢，是的，那很棒。真是美好时光。就顺着演下去了。我想我只是决定也许通过承担那个身份，我能对这种情况有一些控制或发言权。
It was disappointing at first. I see this guy get freaked out, and I was like, oh, no. Like, my whole idea is to make this guy's night. To watch that transformation, to the guy playing pool, doing shots, and getting phone numbers, was really a blast to watch. And I can't decide, in the end, whether I picked the perfect guy or whether I picked the worst guy.
起初很失望。我看到这家伙被吓坏了，我当时想，噢，不。我的初衷是让这人过个好夜晚。看着那种转变，变成玩桌球、喝烈酒、要电话号码的家伙，看得很过瘾。最后我无法决定，我到底是选对了人，还是选错了人。
There may have been a worse Ted somewhere in the world, but probably not in that bar. Sure, he'd had fun, even let them convince him to take the gift cards home. Chris rose to the challenge and became Ted. But by the next morning, he was Chris again, only he was Chris with another man's gift cards, which there was no way he was going to spend.
世界上某个地方可能有一个更糟糕的Ted，但大概不在那个酒吧里。当然，他玩得很开心，甚至让他们说服他把礼品卡带回家。Chris接受了挑战，变成了Ted。但第二天早上，他又变回了Chris，只是Chris带着别人的礼品卡，他根本不可能花掉。
I don't know, it became kind of this weird collection of sacred objects almost. For a year, I kind of saw them as this other, these empowered things.
我不知道，它几乎变成了一种奇怪的神圣物品集合。有一年，我把它视为这种其他的、被赋予权力的东西。
It's sort of like in the sci-fi movie when you-- you know, you come back from being back in time, and you reach in your pocket and you still have the [INAUDIBLE].
这有点像科幻电影里你——你知道，你从回到过去回来，你伸手摸口袋，你还有那东西。
Right, exactly. Or when Tom Cruise wakes up in Eyes Wide Shut in the mask from the night before. It was on his pillow. As much as I wanted to forget it, I woke up and those gift cards were there. It was like, oh, I guess that did happen.
对，没错。或者当汤姆·克鲁斯在《大开眼戒》中醒来时，发现前晚的那个面具在他枕头上。尽管我想忘记它，但我醒来时那些礼品卡就在那儿。这就像，噢，我想那件事真的发生了。
Chris' response over time was different from Ghosts of Pasha's. They came to appreciate the idea in their own way, but it just left Chris feeling vulnerable and a little paranoid. He hated the thought that all those strangers at the bar could just pop up again at any moment. One day, he was sitting on a bench in Union Square when a guy walked up to him and said, hey, Ted. He waved him off, but it was freaky. It didn't help that his memory of the whole thing was a little hazy. For example, he didn't remember giving his phone number out to anyone that night. So you can imagine how he felt when Charlie called him a year later.
Chris随着时间的反应与Ghosts of Pasha不同。他们以自己的方式开始欣赏这个想法，但这只让Chris感到脆弱和有点偏执。他讨厌那种所有酒吧里的陌生人随时可能再次蹦出来的想法。有一天，他正坐在联合广场的长椅上，一个人走过来对他说，嘿，Ted。他把他赶走了，但这很吓人。他对整件事的记忆有点模糊对他没什么帮助。例如，他不记得那天晚上把电话号码给过任何人。所以你可以想象当Charlie一年后给他打电话时他的感受。
And I said, hey, Ted. It's Charlie. How's it going? Your birthday's coming up in a few weeks. We want to know when you want to celebrate it. We want to throw you another party. Wanted to know what you wanted. Like, last year, we got you those Best Buy gift certificates. Do you want that again or is there a different store? Give me a call back. And I gave my number.
我说，嘿，Ted。我是Charlie。最近怎么样？几周后就到你生日了。我们要知道你想什么时候庆祝。我们想再给你办个派对。想知道你想要什么。就像去年，我们给了你那些百思买的礼品卡。你还要那个，还是有别的店？给我回个电话。然后我给了他我的号码。
I didn't hear from him. And as it turns out, a friend of mine knows someone who's a bartender at Dempsy's, where we did Ted's birthday. And Ted is still a regular at that bar, I assume, and he told this bartender, he went up to her and said, do you know the people who did that birthday thing to me last year? And he said, well, could you tell them to stop calling me? And if they're going to be coming around this bar, I'm going to have to stop coming here.
我没收到他的回音。结果，我的一个朋友认识Dempsy's的一位酒保，我们在那儿办了Ted的生日。Ted还是那家酒吧的常客，我想，他告诉了这个酒保，他走到她面前说，你知道去年给我办那个生日派对的人吗？他说，好吧，你能让他们别再给我打电话了吗？如果他们还要来这个酒吧，我就得停止来这儿了。
It really kind of broke my heart, because it had been such a wonderful night and a wonderful experience for us. And it seemed like it had been a wonderful experience for him.
这真的有点让我心碎，因为这对我们来说是个美好的夜晚和美好的体验。而看起来那对他也是一次美好的体验。
I mean, but is it? I mean, did it go well? Is it a success if, a year later, Ted's story has changed?
我是说，但这真的好吗？我是说，它进行得顺利吗？如果一年后，Ted的故事变了，这还能算成功吗？
Well, I mean, it does kind of-- that response definitely made me sad. But regardless of how he feels about it now, I do know that that night was awesome. I kind of sound like the lead singer of Ghosts of Pasha now. Like, I want to tell him and kind of say the same things to him that that guy said to me. You know, like, whatever you say, you had a blast that night. But he did. He did get his $300, and he did get completely drunk, and make friends, even if for only a night. So that night, as it exists in my memory and in the memory of everybody who was there, it was a success.
嗯，我是说，这确实有点——那个回应绝对让我难过。但无论他现在怎么看，我知道那天晚上很棒。我现在听起来像Ghosts of Pasha的主唱了。我是说，我想告诉他，并对他说些那个家伙对我说的话。你知道，无论你怎么说，你那天晚上玩得很开心。但他确实。他确实拿到了他的300美元，他确实喝得酩酊大醉，还交了朋友，即使只是一晚。所以那天晚上，正如它存在于我的记忆中，以及在场所有人的记忆中，它是一个成功。
In the end, Chris did to Charlie what Charlie does so well to other people. He pretended to have an experience that he wasn't actually having, and Charlie thought the fake-out was real. And when he found out the truth, Charlie reacted the way other people do to him in that situation. He was sort of upset, a little hurt. And then he comforted himself by deciding that some part of the fake-out was real.
最后，Chris对Charlie做了Charlie对别人很擅长做的事。他假装有了一次他实际上并没有的经历，而Charlie以为这个戏弄是真的。当他发现真相时，Charlie的反应和别人在那种情况下对他的反应一样。他有点心烦，有点受伤。然后他安慰自己，认定戏弄的某一部分是真的。
And that's the danger of what Charlie does. He believes you'll enjoy sharing his fantasy world whether you do or not. He asks you to leave your own reality and step into his, just like every crazy pantsless guy on the subway.
这就是Charlie做的事情的危险所在。他相信无论你喜不喜欢，你都会喜欢分享他的幻想世界。他让你离开自己的现实，步入他的现实，就像地铁里每一个疯狂的没穿裤子的人一样。
Jorge Just. Coming up, mind games that can turn a girl invisible in front of a neighborhood, a city, and the national media. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio international, when our program continues.
Jorge Just。接下来， mind games会让一个女孩在社区、城市和全国媒体面前变得隐形。稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际的节目，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Mind Games. And we've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Invisible Girl.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，《心理游戏》。我们的节目已经进行到第二幕。第二幕，《隐形女孩》。
You probably remember the story of Elizabeth Smart. Back in 2002, she was abducted from her home in Salt Lake City by a man who believed that God had told him to take her as his wife. She was 14. He was 49. And he already had a wife, Wanda, who was 57 years old. His name was Brian David Mitchell, but he called himself Emmanuel. Thousands of volunteers searched for Elizabeth Smart for months. Her picture was everywhere.
你可能还记得Elizabeth Smart的故事。回到2002年，她在盐湖城的家中被一个男人绑架，那个人相信上帝告诉他娶她为妻。她14岁。他49岁。他已经有一个妻子Wanda，57岁。他的名字是Brian David Mitchell，但他自称Emmanuel。成千上万的志愿者搜索了Elizabeth Smart几个月。她的照片无处不在。
But now we know that two months after the kidnapping, Mitchell and Wanda brought Elizabeth to the place that nobody would expect them to go, downtown Salt Lake City, right in the middle of the whole thing. They'd walk the streets. Nobody recognized her. Scott Carrier lives in this neighborhood, the one where Elizabeth Smart lived, the one where her captors brought her later. And he talked to his neighbors about what happened in their heads that they didn't recognize her.
但现在我们知道，绑架后两个月，Mitchell和Wanda把Elizabeth带到了没人会想到他们会去的地方，盐湖城市中心，就在整件事的眼皮底下。他们走在街上。没人认出她。Scott Carrier住在这个社区，就是Elizabeth Smart住的那个社区，她绑架者后来带她去的那个社区。他和邻居们谈论了他们脑袋里发生了什么，以至于没认出她。
Our neighborhood is on a hillside, sandwiched between the University of Utah and downtown. The closest thing we've got here to a liberal enclave, and relatively diverse, at least economically. At the bottom of the hill are the mansions built in the late 1800s, the street lined with old sycamores, some shops and stores, apartment buildings. Going up the hillside, the houses generally get newer and bigger.
我们的社区在山坡上，夹在犹他大学和市中心之间。这里是我们所拥有的最接近自由派飞地的地方，而且相对多元化，至少在经济上是这样。山下是1800年代末建造的豪宅，街道两旁种满了老悬铃木，还有一些商店、店铺和公寓楼。顺着山坡往上走，房子通常变得更新、更大。
Elizabeth Smart and her family lived about a mile from our house. After she was abducted, her pictures seemed to be everywhere, taped to light posts, in every storefront window. She was on the news every day for months. But she was here, with her two abductors, walking around on the streets, and nobody figured it out. Nobody recognized her, partly because they were disguised.
Elizabeth Smart和她的家人离我们家大约一英里。她被绑架后，她的照片似乎到处都是，贴在灯柱上，在每个店面的窗户里。她几个月来每天都在新闻上出现。但她就在这里，和她的两名绑架者一起，走在街上，没人发现。没人认出她，部分原因是他们伪装了。
They wore white robes. Elizabeth and Wanda had their heads covered, veils across their faces, revealing only their eyes. Mitchell, or Emmanuel, had a turban, a long beard, and a walking stick. For two and a half months, from August until October, they stayed pretty much right in the neighborhood, and a lot of people saw them.
他们穿着白袍。Elizabeth和Wanda头上盖着东西，面纱遮住脸，只露出眼睛。Mitchell，或者说Emmanuel，戴着头巾，留着长胡子，拿着手杖。两个半月，从八月到十月，他们基本上就住在社区里，很多人都见过他们。
Yeah, I did. I saw them. I saw them walking. I was at the gas station, and we were washing the car.
是的，我见过。我见过他们。我见过他们走路。我当时在加油站，我们正在洗车。
Yeah, they were walking right past Blockbuster Video, right towards the supermarket.
是的，他们就在百视达影音店旁边走过，正对着超市。
And we were up on 4 South, at the Wendy's. And we went in there for a second to see if they had salad bar. And they didn't, but on the way out, he came up, Emmanuel, or Brian David Mitchell.
我们当时在南四街的温迪餐厅。我们进去待了一会儿，看他们有没有沙拉吧。他们没有，但在出来的时候，他过来了，Emmanuel，或者说Brian David Mitchell。
And they were all wearing their robes. And they were walking slowly up the street-- I don't know where they were going-- in a single-file line.
他们都穿着长袍。他们慢慢地沿着街道走着——我不知道他们要去哪儿——排成一列。
I saw him. And the guy, he stopped, and he stopped, talking to somebody. I think he asked for a cigarette.
我看见他了。那个人，他停下来了，他停下来和某人交谈。我想他要了支烟。
And the two women stood back a little bit. And he came up, and he was very humble, and he asked for some money for food. He didn't seem threatening.
那两个女人稍微退后了一点。他走过来，表现得很谦卑，他要了一些食物钱。他看起来不像是有威胁。
But I saw the girl eye to eye, and she looked familiar. Even that, her pictures, were in the door, you know? But it did not click. It did not click.
但我跟那个女孩对视过，她看起来很眼熟。即使是那样，她的照片都在门上，你知道吗？但就是没对上号。没对上号。
It wasn't like they just showed up out of nowhere. Mitchell and Barzee had been homeless, on the street, wearing their robes for a couple years before they took Elizabeth. My friend, Trent Harris, thought he knew the guy all too well.
这不像他们凭空出现一样。Mitchell和Barzee在绑架Elizabeth之前，已经在街上流浪、穿着长袍几年了。我的朋友Trent Harris觉得他太了解那个家伙了。
Well, he was kind of a fixture on the streets of Salt Lake City. He was always asking for money in front of the ZCMI Shopping Mall. I remember he'd sit out there with this just pathetic look on his face. Oh, he was annoying. He was really annoying.
嗯，他是盐湖城市中心街头的一道风景线。他总是坐在ZCMI购物中心前要钱。我记得他坐在那儿，脸上带着那种可怜巴巴的表情。噢，他很烦人。他真的太烦人了。
I'd seen them before, and I thought they were just crazy extremist fundamentalists who'd walk around.
我以前见过他们，我以为他们只是到处走动的疯狂极端原教旨主义者。
That's my son, Milo. He's the same age as Elizabeth and went to grade school with her. We have a picture of Milo and Elizabeth at a birthday party when they were four. He's dressed as a cowboy. She's a princess. My wife, Hilary, gave her dance lessons. In September, Milo saw Elizabeth with Mitchell and Barzee when he was at a gas station washing the car.
那是我儿子，Milo。他和Elizabeth同岁，和她一起上小学。我们有一张Milo和Elizabeth四岁时在生日派对上的照片。他扮成牛仔。她是公主。我妻子Hilary教她跳舞。九月份，Milo在加油站洗车时看到了Elizabeth和Mitchell还有Barzee。
They walked by me. I was within 10 feet of them. I'm pretty sure she could've recognized me if she'd just seen me. I bet she did.
他们从我身边走过。我就在他们10英尺范围内。我很确定如果她见过我的话，她能认出我。我打赌她一定认出我了。
But she didn't say anything, and Milo didn't recognize her.
但她什么也没说，Milo也没认出她。
I didn't think anything of it, because that's ridiculous. Like, she's walking around in the middle of daylight. It wouldn't be her. It didn't even cross my mind that it would be her. Who would do that? Who would actually take the person that everybody is looking for, the most sought after person in the whole state pretty much? That's risking your life. If somebody found him and recognized her, they would've killed him.
我没多想，因为那太荒谬了。我是说，她在大白天走来走去。不可能是她。我脑子里根本没闪过那是她的念头。谁会这么做？谁会真的带走全州都在寻找的人，基本上是全州最受关注的人？那是在冒生命危险。如果有人发现并认出她，他们会杀了他。
Part of the reason the disguise worked is because, whether we saw him as a pest, or a harmless eccentric, or a crazy fundamentalist, we saw him as a loser. Someone to be pitied or scorned, written off, ignored, forgotten. And we don't really look at people like that. We look away.
伪装奏效的部分原因是，无论我们将他视为害虫、无害的怪人，还是疯狂的原教旨主义者，我们都把他看作一个失败者。一个值得怜悯或鄙视、被写掉、被忽视、被遗忘的人。我们并没有真正注视那样的人。我们移开视线。
There's another reason we didn't recognize Elizabeth, and it has to do with a thing that's specific to this culture and this place right here. In any other state, if you saw Mitchell and Barzee walking along with a young girl in tow, you'd think it was their daughter. But when we saw it here, we thought she was his new polygamist wife.
我们没认出Elizabeth还有另一个原因，这与此地特有的文化有关。在任何其他州，如果你看到Mitchell和Barzee带着一个年轻女孩，你会认为那是他们的女儿。但当我们在这里看到它时，我们认为她是他的新多妻制妻子。
And I remember saying to myself, you know, I'm used to seeing Emmanuel David with one woman, but now he had two, and the other one was much younger. And I remember thinking, how did he manage to pull that off?
我记得对自己说，你知道，我习惯看到Emmanuel David带一个女人，但现在他有两个，另一个要年轻得多。我记得我在想，他是怎么搞定那个的？
And when he came up to us the day at Wendy's, I felt bad for those two women..
当他在温迪那天走到我们面前时，我为那两个女人感到难过。
Here's my friend, Dana Costello.
这是我的朋友，Dana Costello。
And I especially noticed that the other one was young. But I didn't think that's their daughter. I assumed immediately, just in my head, that she was his new wife. It just came to my head. Oh, look, he got another wife.
我特别注意到另一个很年轻。但我没想那是他们的女儿。我立刻就在脑子里假设她是他的新妻子。这直接就进到我脑子里了。噢，看，他又找了个老婆。
You didn't anything bad about it when you saw that he had two wives.
你看到他有两个老婆时，没觉得有什么不对劲。
I didn't. I really didn't.
我没觉得。我真的没觉得。
Officially, the Mormons stopped believing in polygamy in 1890, but it still goes on here and there. And many people in Salt Lake City have polygamist ancestors. And when we run into it, there's a sense of shame and embarrassment mixed in with American ideals of freedom of religion. And the end result is we just ignore it and let it be. We don't want to look at it.
官方上，摩门教徒在1890年停止信仰多妻制，但这在这里时有发生。盐湖城的许多人都有多妻制的祖先。当我们遇到它时，会有一种羞耻感和尴尬感，夹杂着美国的宗教自由理想。最终结果就是我们只是忽视它，顺其自然。我们不想看它。
What's especially annoying about this is the possibility that Mitchell was smart enough to figure it out and use this weakness against us. The most amazing encounter with Elizabeth happened in September, not long before the threesome left town to spend the winter in southern California. There was a party in a big house full of bohemians. Mitchell, Barzee, and Elizabeth were walking by, maybe on their way back to their camp in the foothills, and they stopped in.
特别让人恼火的是，Mitchell可能足够聪明，能弄明白这一点并利用这个弱点对付我们。最令人震惊的与Elizabeth的相遇发生在九月份，就在这三人离开城镇去南加州过冬之前不久。有一个派对在充满波西米亚风格的大房子里举行。Mitchell、Barzee和Elizabeth路过，也许是在回山脚下营地的路上，他们停下来了。
Amber Meriwether and Russell Ferrell were there that night.
Amber Meriwether和Russell Ferrell那天晚上在那儿。
There's always people in costumes at the parties there. So we just thought that they were just people in costume, just being silly.
那里的派对上总有人穿奇装异服。所以我们只是以为他们是穿戏服的人，只是在闹着玩。
He drew a lot of attention to himself, because he had a lot of preaching going on. He was an obvious preacher, but it seemed dichotomous that he was meanwhile bumming beers.
他吸引了很多注意力，因为他一直在布道。他是个明显的传教士，但与此同时他在蹭啤酒，这看起来很矛盾。
It looked like he had never seen food or drink in his entire life. The man's was obviously starving and a complete obnoxious drunk.
看起来他这辈子从没见过食物或饮料一样。那个人显然饿坏了，而且是个令人讨厌的醉鬼。
Finally, he got a hold of some local-made absinthe, which is the tincture of wormwood made famous by the impressionists back in the turn of the century.
最后，他搞到了一些当地酿造的苦艾酒，就是世纪之交印象派画家们出名的苦艾草酊剂。
He was just drinking it like crazy, and he was getting super sloshed. And he was trying to get the two girls to drink it.
他就在疯狂地喝，喝得酩酊大醉。他还试图让那两个女孩喝。
Somebody at the party took a picture of Elizabeth standing there in the kitchen. You may have seen it, a veil across her face, her eyes so clearly now the same eyes in the posters hanging up all over town. The people at the party were so close, but still they couldn't see her. It was just too absurd. Amber even went up and talked to her.
派对上的某个人拍了一张Elizabeth站在厨房的照片。你可能见过，面纱遮住她的脸，她眼神现在很清楚，就是挂在城里海报上的那双眼睛。派对上的人离得那么近，却依然看不见她。这太荒谬了。Amber甚至走过去和她说话。
I walked into the kitchen, and I remember looking at her a couple of times and thinking that she looked familiar. I had been seeing her pictures everywhere, but I didn't connect the two. I just thought, I mean, come on, you're not going to think Elizabeth Smart's going to be drunk at a party. Or I guess she wasn't drunk. I don't think she drank anything, actually.
我走进厨房，我记得看着她好几次，心想她看起来很眼熟。我到处都在看她的照片，但我没把两者联系起来。我只是想，我是说，得了吧，你不会认为Elizabeth Smart会醉倒在一个派对上。或者我想她没醉。其实我觉得她什么都没喝。
But I walked up to her and I just asked her, where do I know her from? That she looks really familiar. And she didn't really say anything back. And the man, Emmanuel, came up, he said, no, you don't know her.
但我走过去问她，我是从哪儿认识她的？她看起来真的很眼熟。她没说什么。那个男人，Emmanuel，走过来说，不，你不认识她。
Someone said, well, was this guy using some sort of black magic over the whole scenario? Putting a veil, so to speak, over everyone's perception? His approach to her and the other woman was very-- he was quite the patriarch.
有人说，好吧，这人是对整个场景用了什么黑魔法吗？给每个人的认知都蒙上了一层面纱？他对她和另一个女人的那种方式很——他表现得很有大家长风范。
I think he was so believing of his righteousness or his potency of his prophecy, and he would do these little things to prove to himself, more and more so, that he was being protected by God because it was right what he was doing, that every time he took Elizabeth out and that she wasn't noticed, it was true that Elizabeth was his. And he really believed that he could be protected in this way, that he made it happen in this weird way. It did happen.
我认为他太相信自己的正义感或预言的能力了，他会做这些小动作来向自己证明，越多越好，因为他所做的一切是正确的，所以他受到了上帝的保护，每当他把Elizabeth带出去而没人注意到时，Elizabeth是他的就是真的。他真的相信他能以这种方式受到保护，他以这种奇怪的方式让它发生了。它确实发生了。
He had literally put a spell over Salt Lake City, that no one would see him. It was magical. I think he believed that.
他真的给盐湖城施了咒，没人会看见他。那是魔法。我认为他是这么相信的。
I think it's more likely we didn't see Elizabeth because we thought the guy who took her would be a monster, a bogeyman, and we expected him to appear in that form. Mitchell looked like the opposite of a bogeyman. A bogeyman stands in the shadows and jumps out at you. Mitchell stood right in front of us and sort of became invisible.
我觉得更有可能是我们没看见Elizabeth，因为我们认为带走她的人会是个怪物，是个妖魔，我们期待他以那种形式出现。Mitchell看起来和妖魔恰恰相反。妖魔站在阴影里跳出来吓你。Mitchell就站在我们面前，某种程度上变成了隐形。
When Elizabeth was discovered nine months after her abduction, we all realized our mistake. And it was like a combination of being really happy she was alive mixed with feelings of being duped in a rather serious and sinister way. We realized we were partly to blame, that there was something within us that made us deny the obvious. And that hurt. My son, Milo, thought about it for months afterwards. He's 17 now.
Elizabeth在绑架九个月后被发现时，我们都意识到我们错了。那感觉就像是既非常高兴她还活着，又夹杂着一种被以相当严重和险恶的方式愚弄的感受。我们意识到我们要负部分责任，我们内心有某种东西让我们否认了显而易见的事情。那很痛。我儿子，Milo，在那之后的几个月里一直在想这个。他现在17岁了。
Did you feel bad when you realized that you'd missed it?
当你意识到你错过了它时，你觉得难过吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Tell me what you felt like when you heard it.
告诉我当你听到它时你是什么感觉。
Well, I mean, when I heard that she was walking around with that guy, it was like, holy crap, I've been right there. Like, I've walked by those guys, and just passed it off as nothing. It sounds bad, but the way that he kept her was he convinced her to stay with him. He took her up into the mountains and-- he's not a good guy. He's a terrible person. He took her up into the mountains and somehow brainwashed her, convinced her that she was meant to be with him and he was the son of God. He thinks he's Jesus.
嗯，我是说，当我听说她和那个人走在一起时，那感觉就像，天哪，我就在那儿。就像，我走过那些人身边，却把它当成什么都没有。这听起来很糟糕，但他困住她的方式是他说服她留在他身边。他带她上山，然后——他不是个好人。他是个糟糕的人。他带她上山，不知怎么洗了她的脑，让她相信她注定要和他在一起，他是上帝之子。他以为他是耶稣。
If I could have been there-- Like, if I had known then, if I had just been able to think about it-- I don't know, it made me pretty angry. Like, maybe if I could just go back to then, that day. Thinking about that more than anything.
如果我能在那儿——就像，如果我当时就知道，如果我当时能想到——我不知道，这让我很生气。就像，也许如果我能回到那时，那一天。想这个比想什么都多。
I saw Elizabeth a couple weeks ago, downtown between the shopping malls. She was on one side of the street and I was on the other. At first, I thought she was a woman in her 20s, maybe a legal secretary, because that's how she was dressed. But then, when the light changed and we walked by each other, I thought, who is that? She looks like a young Mariel Hemingway, really distinctive and beautiful eyes. And then I realized it was Elizabeth Smart, right as she went by me. It was like seeing a rock star or a mythic heroine. She'd journeyed to a dark world, and it seemed, looking at her, that she'd come back with her innocence intact. And this made me feel hopeful, like maybe things are going to turn out OK.
几周前我在市中心商场之间见到了Elizabeth。她在街的一边，我在另一边。起初，我以为她是个20多岁的女人，也许是个法律秘书，因为她是那样打扮的。但后来，当绿灯亮起，我们走过彼此身边时，我想，那是谁？她看起来像年轻时的Mariel Hemingway，非常独特且美丽的眼睛。然后我意识到是Elizabeth Smart，就在她从我身边经过时。那感觉就像看到一个摇滚明星或神话英雄。她去过一个黑暗的世界，看着她，感觉她似乎带回了她纯真的本质。这让我感到充满希望，也许一切都会好起来的。
Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City. His story received support from hearingvoices.com, which gets some of its support from The Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
Scott Carrier在盐湖城。他的故事得到了hearingvoices.com的支持，该网站得到公共广播公司的部分支持。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Aaron Scott. Seth Lind is our production manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
好吧，我们的节目今天由Julie Snyder和我自己制作，还有Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, 和 Lisa Pollak。Todd Bachmann和Aaron Scott提供了制作帮助。Seth Lind是我们的制作经理。Adrianne Mathiowetz负责我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where we have all kinds of brand-new holiday merch for your holiday shopping needs. Also, if you're so inclined, you can go there and donate to our show. WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who insists,
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，那里有各种各样的全新假日周边，满足您的假日购物需求。此外，如果您愿意，您可以去那里为我们的节目捐款。WBEZ的管理监督由Torey Malatia先生负责，他坚持说，
I'm the guy from the airport.
我是那个人，来自机场。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周回来，收听更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。